donc les hochets revient de le publier
votre premier livre dont qui s'appelle
salomé et on va faire un jeu si vous
voulez bien si on va jouer comme si on
était en 1969
ouais l'année érotique ouais je sais pas
ce que l'on croit tous les années 60
était bien mais en sorte que je
travaillais à dim dam dom et or janvier
69 serge gainsbourg a pour sa chanson 69
année érotique et à la télévision il
voulait pas la passe et on arrivait on
prend des risques en irak a passé 69
année érotique
ça fait toute une histoire il a fallu
que des digues galère à y voir de plus
où dans le gouvernement français pour
avoir le feu vert pour pâques pour
passer cette source
maintenant nous raconte les années 60
c'était la liberté tout seul ouais alors
on va se retrouver en 69 on va faire une
interview flash back
qu'on soit née à donges bonsoir nous
sommes toujours heureux de recevoir ici
un jeune qui débute
vous avez 27 ans je crois c'est votre
première télévision non non non j'ai eu
à 5-6 ans le grand prix du film sur
l'art à hôpital de bergame et j'étais
interviewé par la rai en italien vous
savez faites pas votre âge 1 j'ai plus
vieux noms bien bien c'est bien alors
françois en quelques mots vous êtes né
en belgique votre père est un grand
romancier catholique vous avez fait vos
études chez les jésuites
ensuite vous avez appris le cinéma à
l'idhec et aujourd'hui vous sortez votre
premier roman salomé ça parle de quoi
françois salomé fait une sorte de
monologue très obsessionnelle d'un jeune
homme qu'on pourrait appeler dans le
vent les pressions est à la mode en ce
moment donc qui se promènent dans toute
l'europe qui voyagent beaucoup qui est
obsédé par le cinéma et les femmes parce
qu'il pense que la meilleure façon de
faire du cinéma c'est de faire faire de
jolies choses a dit olli femme j'ai vu
formule qui l'arrosé truffaut ouais
c'est au fusil il a dit qu'il disait en
fait trois fois copié ce refus c'est moi
sur truffaut qui peut être les ai reçus
et il y aura pompé par courrèges du mal
à écrire ce livre
pas du tout c'était un plaisir quand
j'ai dit continue alors j'étais très
très heureux j'écrivais tout le temps et
voilà est-ce que vous pensez que ce
livre va être suivie de beaucoup
d'autres françois bailly côté le
problème c'est bien celui-là je ne m'en
si je vais le publier
et en plus je vais signer un contrat je
vais dans quelques mois je vais mettre
en scène tristan et isolde de wagner
donc je t'aime bien mais j'ai fait un
film non non non au contraire je suis
avant la lettre
comment on ride appeler ça un jour
multimédia vous écrivez depuis longtemps
j'ai commencé à l'âge de neuf ans un
premier roman j'ai malheureusement perdu
et si ça marche pour vous vous irez chez
qui vu que c'est la télévision vizille
mon éditeur voudrait mais je suis pas
sûr est est ce que vous pensez qu'un
jour vous fêterez vos quarante ans de
carrière à la télévision
est-ce que rencontre la télévision dans
40 ans pas sûr est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils auront encore des cheveux dans 40
ans mais il fait déjà perdu à peine
quatre ans j'ai donné mes cheveux j'ai
toujours écrit ma wii jeu une fois qu'on
a goûté à cette drogue
on a du mal à s'en défaire les
événements récents de mai-68 vous avez
vécu comme en a mais j'étais à la
sorbonne content content quand on a
repris la sorbonne et je me suis je me
vois c'était y'a pas longtemps et
quelques mois je
haranguant une salle en leur disant
camarades en parents nous de le rtf
parce que je travaillais din daeng
n'avait jamais la clé une huilerie
cognacq-jay de la régie finale
alors je dis ça très fort là il y avait
plein de fric évidemment dans la salle
et après je sors dans la rue avec
quelques camarades il ya une voiture le
rtl là que je répète on peut aisément
sur les ondes on va s'emparer de lui rtf
résultat un quart d'heure [ __ ] il y
avait 25 qu'un de crs qui ont entouré la
rue cognacq-jay donc j'ai pas pu
comparer le rtf vous écoutez quoi comme
musique en ce moment alors là j'ai vu
être intarissable jeu je rentre
d'amsterdam où j'ai rencontré un groupe
je vais le ro brooks fils et quatre
garçons formidable jubilé en gazier pour
mon tristan de wagner et je voudrais
mettre pendant confiant de cas de wagner
les maîtres e puis je vais à londres
acheter des disques de musique inde où
les années soixante dix qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui pratiquement vous les voyez
comment françois je suis très content
que ma compagne est enceinte je vais
devenir père et je voudrais qu'en 2000
il y aura des voitures volantes je crois
pas au progrès non si c'est un progrès
moi je pense qu'en 2000 c'est bien mais
ira encore des environs cordes et des
porte plumes
vous pensez quoi les écrivains contre 60
ans aujourd'hui les gens formidables
je connais pierre klossowski qui doit
voir 64 ans rené-charles 9 à 65 ans sont
également de très bons auteurs est ce
que vous pensez qu'un jour la france
gagnera la coupe du monde de football à
mon avis lui trois buts à zéro et je
pense contre le brésil du temps et faire
n'importe quoi
ouais est-ce qu'on enseigne dans tous
les cas c'est précis c'est tout ce qu'on
peut dire est ce que vous aimez bien
michel drucker mais on ne connaît pas
encore la jeune animateur qui commence à
bien marcher michel drucker vous
connaissez pas qu'est ce qui pourrait
vous faire arrêter d'écrire aujourd'hui
la mort pensez quoi françois de ces
écrivains qui donnent leur manuscrit à
leurs éditeurs avec un retard incroyable
à sa saison j admire beaucoup j'y arrive
pas mais j'aimerais bien une ressembler
votre éditeur mâcon titiller sur
l'écriture d'un roman intitulé trois
jours chez ma mère vous pensez qu'il
sera terminé quand mon avis on y pour 20
ans